you can always take a bit of a clue as
to what themes are by looking at the
word and thinking about well what I know
about this now there are two important
words that we use one more common than
the other that both had the same kind of
basis as this work okay
the more common word is cryptic
what does cryptic mean if I say oh
that's kind of cryptic right it
generally means give me a synonym
mysterious confusing right unclear so
that's why we have cryptic crosswords
and there's crosswords and they make
sense in like here's a rule and then
there's cryptic crosswords don't know if
you've ever read the clues for cryptic
crossword it's just like is this what
what is this I don't even like it just
doesn't make any sense so cryptic is
about mysterious or unclear right now
that's an adjective the verb that we
would attach to this is the word encrypt
right
so if cryptic is mysterious then to
encrypt right is to make something
mysterious right to make it cryptic and
cryptography is the art and science of
encryption right of how do you take
something which is sensible and
meaningful and make it into something
that is hard to understand right why
would you ever want to do that why would
you make something that's clear up into
something confusing why would you do
that
good give it to make the truth right
harder to find or harder to see okay so
that's why I like to call it the art and
science of keeping secrets I think
that's the UM the simplest way to
understand it right you've got ideas
your are truths you got fact but you
don't want everyone to know okay so a
classic example of this I was in the
Renaissance right there people like who
did you have you had your you're da
Vinci's and your Raphael's and you're
all these incredibly smart people right
and they made these discoveries and they
invented things but they didn't want
people to know what their discoveries
interventions were okay so they would
encrypt them they would write them
backward to write them in code okay or
they would use these things called
ciphers okay now this is important this
is our first subheading okay what's a
cipher a cipher is a tool right a
mathematical tool which is why it comes
undone that's right for hands okay it's
a very simple idea okay so there's a
whole variety of ciphers and I'm only
going to teach you about a very few
number just the ones that are simple
enough to wrap our heads around okay so
the first kind of cipher is a
substitution cipher okay and we're all
going to do one today okay a
substitution cipher is very simple right
you've got letters we have 26 letters in
our alphabet right a B C D and so on so
the simple idea behind a substitution
cipher
Matt cicadas over the simple idea behind
a substitution cipher as the name
implies is going to take all of these
letters and substitute them for
something else okay now the way we do it
and the reason why it comes under Matz
is because all of the letters or
twenty-six of them can be very easily
numerically represented so we can call
this letter 1 then 2 then 3 then 4 and
so on so the simplest most famous client
a substitution cipher that I'm going to
teach you today is called the Caesar
cipher because apparently the Romans
used to do it okay as you'll discover
it's actually not that good it's not
very good as a cipher it's not very good
at making things mysterious right it's
very easy to break right but that's part
of the reason why it's easy for us to
wrap our heads around how does a Caesar
cipher work it uses if you remember this
or you might not remember it depending
on what you did in the last thing is it
uses a branch of math called modular or
clock arithmetic could you raise your
hand if you have ever heard of modular
arithmetic heads up straight it's like I
heard about it but do not remember
that's a cat right hands down boys of
the month in oh yeah yes sir sir modular
short for and we use the word mod to UM
abbreviate it okay I will teach you how
much of everything
and you'll see why a term called clock
arithmetic I'll show you how it works
really easy okay the idea of modular
estimate is taking remainders okay okay
so this is a new subheading underneath
Percy does have to show you how it works
okay so we might say have a division
under and you pick a number and pick a
number
okay so say I want to do module in
petite with a base of 5 okay so I'm
going to work out the remainders after
dividing by 5
so this is really easy the way I would
write it is I'll take for instance okay
what's one when you divide by five how
many times can you fit five into that
not a good question the answer is you
can't fit it any times right so if I say
mod 5 after taking out zero lots of five
ones left and the answer is just the one
right so 1 mod 5 is just 1 ok 2 mod 5
would just be 2 and 3 month and so on
okay but where it starts the interesting
is when you hit 5 ok because 5 1 5
what's the remainder when you divide by
5 near to 0 right uh-huh
ok and you can keep going right let's do
let's do a bigger number say uh because
I picked 5 it's very easy so if I say 23
mod 5 you just have to take away all the
multiples of 5 which is 20 and that
leaves you with 3 ok simple so how does
this apply to this right we are going to
choose a number any number you like
right um actually
let's pick 5 since we've been talking
about it ok and for all of these numbers
I'm going to add that number on ok
so for instance this would become our
six and seven eight nine and so now
here's I'm going to do I'm gonna replace
and I need a few more letters here ok
don't be so everywhere I see an A
right I'm going to replace it with the
sixth verb which is f right everywhere I
see a B I'm going to replace it with the
seventh letter which is a G and you can
see what's happening right now
why is modular arithmetic important to
this because so far all I'm doing is
adding numbers well as I add things are
fine when you go 10 11 12 and so on okay
but eventually right you're going to hit
let up 25 and then letter 26 okay now
quick question
you think you see if you how quickly go
back up this means right when I see an a
when I see the first letter I'll replace
it with the sixth letter what letter
will I replace because n what number
would have been it would be the twenty
first letter right the twenty first
letter here I will replace with the 26
letter which is there so what is the
twenty first level is it t let's see TUV
wxy Z so 26 25 24 23 22 21 to that count
right okay so when I see a u right when
I co dot u that's letter 21 I should
replace it with letter 26 and my cypher
so far is fine but what happens when I
see a V okay so that's letter 22 so when
I add 5 to it I get 27 but I don't have
a 27th letter so what I do is I replace
it with 27 mod what should I do it by I
should do it by 26 goodnight because I
have 26 letters in my alphabet okay so
this will take me all the way back to 1
I should replace a V with an A which I
guess would mean I would replace a W
which is letter 23 with the second low
which is a bit and you get the idea x y
and z which of course should be replaced
with an e right because the first third
over here is an F so it comes around
okay so does that make sense see what's
going on so in fact um Caesar ciphers
can be man you can actually construct
one for yourself by having two
concentric circles right on the inside
you have all the letters in the alphabet
right on the outside you have all the
letters of the alphabet and then what I
would do is I rotate one of them right
so it's shifted along all plus five so
this is often also called a shift cipher
okay so here's what I would like you to
do okay I would like you all to write
out a message okay and then I would like
you to choose a letter to deliver right
so I'm not sure is matter choose a
number to shift by it could be we chose
five it could be ten eleven whatever
letter you whatever number you like okay
and then shift it over and then hand it
to your friend and see if they can work
out number one
what number did they choose and number
two what's the message supposed to be so
write out your own message obviously not
too long because just a sentence because
I'll take too long to do this
okay pick your own number shift
everything over use your cipher on it
encrypt it and hand it to your friend
and see if they can undo it
off you go